how would you describe like this season
um in comparison to season one for fans
like what can they expect
yeah uh so i think for season one we had
we had a lot to introduce we had a lot
of characters a lot of themes
a lot of action that we just really had
to get all of that
storyline out there to and
see season one is really setting the
foundation for what season two is just
really
digging into um so
i really just expect like the
elaboration for
characters for the stories for the
friendships at all of it
yeah amazing and i know the season one
came
out kind of at the beginning of
everyone's like quarantine
and everyone was staying at home like
did you expect the show to like
get the reaction that i did and how big
it got cuz it's really become this like
phenomenon
um it's like there's there's a part of
me that like i
had a really good feeling it was going
to do amazing that people were going to
love it because we loved it so much and
when you put that much heart into
something
you can only hope that somebody sees
your art
and feels the love that you put into it
and i think
that that's what our audience felt they
really felt the
authentic energy that we brought to it
and
oh
right nothing but it's done so well and
i'm so happy there's a second season
and speaking of season two from what
i've seen we already start to see
kiara and pope and kind of like where
the relationship
is at and i know it's going to be on
everyone's mind
so can you tease us anything like what's
going on between them or how the
relationship's developing like
the fans need to know yeah um
i think pope and kiara are two
characters that like when they're
completely separate
have a lot going on and then within the
friendship
have a lot going on and then in the
relationship have a lot going
on so i think really this season which
you can
um which you can expect to see out of
this is like really us figuring out
what exactly we're feeling it's a lot of
a lot of dtr
um defining the relationship and
really us figuring out where we stand
between a friendship or a relationship
yeah absolutely and as well
we always know that the pose are going
to get up to something crazy it's never
a dull moment
in the show they're always coming to
someone's rescue especially
from what i've seen um so how would you
describe
like the journey that your characters
like your character
and rudy's character everyone's
character kind of goes through
like during the season like what kind of
journey do you think they go on
yeah i mean i think because because we
are all teenagers
in the show um we are
really figuring things out about
ourselves
and within the main
theme of the show like i think
us going after the gold the gold
represents so much more than the gold
it's really
john v's attachment to a part of himself
it's really like
a part of him that we're figuring out so
that he can like sum up his identity
and i think we see this and
something new with pope this season
where we're
trying where it's not really about what
we're going after and it's really about
like
figuring out ourselves and
how we help each other doing that yeah
for sure
and just to kind of wrap things up um i
just want to talk about pride month
because we're at the end we're on june
3rd but really there's no end there
should never be an
end um but you know you become never end
there is no
it never ends and you know you've been
very open
about your sexuality you made tech talks
about it you've spoken a lot
about it like how does it feel to for
you to be
such a role model and make like inspire
so many
young or even older like lgbtq
um people in the community like how does
that make you feel with pride month kind
of coming to an end
yeah i mean that is such a
a heavy thing to like hold on your
shoulders in one way but at the same
time it's like to be a beacon of
light for anyone no matter if it's
like a dim small flashlight or if it is
the sun you know like i to be
to bring light and inspiration to anyone
i mean i get messages
constantly of people telling me how i
inspired them to come out or
or something like that and it's truly a
very special feeling